our CBS News battleground tracker poll
also finds an overwhelming majority of
Americans are optimistic about the
economy 76 percent of voters rated as
very or somewhat good but who gets to
take credit CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger is here with a fact
check we always like fact checks Jill
good to see you
president Trump at rallies constantly
says we now have the hottest economy on
the planet what do we con him say well I
think the most important thing to
remember is that economic cycles are
long and so this current upturn started
back in June of 2009 all the way back
then and from 2009 till about 2017
through those years we've seen growth at
about let's say two and a quarter some
times it popped up to two and a half
percent half head growth it's happened
growth exactly this year there is a
little bit of a supercharge we've had
quarterly growth that's been very good
and for the entire year for all of 2018
it looks like growths gonna come in at
about 3% interestingly enough that would
be the best growth since 2005 but it
comes at some cost because in doing so
we saw a lot of spending by the
government the deficit has widened and
frankly that could actually be a problem
next year because if the deficit is up
pretty high and we are having problems
with tariffs we could see growth cool
next year so economists are telling me
3% growth will be great this year net
sugar high may not last into 2019 the
tax cut also contributed to the sugar
high as well job growth continues to be
steady as well last month we saw 250,000
jobs not bad right
yes and I think this far into a recovery
the job situation is really terrific
right because we know that job growth is
accelerates early in a recovery but to
have more than 200,000 jobs a month
every single month in 2018 is a really
good number unemployment it's down to a
49 year low three point seven percent
and also good news on wages which have
just started to accelerate up by just
over three percent from a year ago any
question how sustainable this is Jill
always great to have you on I'm glad you
got the white memo it's exactly
John back to you